So, spontaner Stream so am Montagmittag, 12.45 Uhr.
Ist nämlich aufgefallen, dass ich mir, glaube ich, noch nie wirklich jetzt die endgültige Version...
Oh, was ist die endgültige? Endgültige Version ist es jetzt ja nicht sein.
Die releaste Version von WSL 2 und WSLG angeschaut habe.
Oder wenn, dann ist es eine ganze Weile her, wo das noch nicht offiziell rausgekommen ist.
Und was auch nicht richtig funktioniert hat, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Zumindest, ich muss mir das mal angucken, weil ich das eventuell mal auf der Arbeit vorschlagen will,
dass wir das versuchen sollten mal zu etablieren bei uns, dass das zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Da muss ich aber erstmal wissen, ob das was taugt.
Wir probieren das Ganze in der VM. Es kann sein, dass es nicht funktionieren wird in der VM.
Das muss ich gleich dazu sagen, weil WSL 2 braucht ja selbst wiederum eine VM.
Und auch wenn Nested-Virtualisierung geht, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob WSL per Nested-Virtualisierung unter Windows 11 funktioniert.
Kein Blasen Schimmer.
Echt? Gibt es da einen? Zeig mal.
Hacker News.
Hacker News, was gibt es da hier?
WSL. Ah ja. Tatsächlich, guck mal da.
Was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Wunderbar.
WSL 1.3.10 Brings Experimental Memory Reclaim.
Moment, das konnte es bisher noch nicht.
Einmal angefordertes Memory ist immer behaltenes Memory.
Also einmal fette Anwendung gestartet, halber RAM weg, oder wie?
Naja, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Bist du in der Schule? Ja, dann GLHF.
Sollte gehen in der VM.
Also ich bilde mir ein, wir haben es das letzte Mal ausprobiert und das ging, aber irgendwelche Probleme gab es.
Habt ihr eigentlich eine Frauenquote bei euch? Ne, wir haben keine Frauenquote, aber wir haben ein paar Frauen.
Oder haben wir? Sekunde. Ja doch, klar.
Haben wir.
Ich muss hier gerade in mich gehen. Also so viele sind es nicht, aber ja, wir haben tatsächlich ein paar.
Ich glaube in der IT ist halt nach wie vor 90% Männer.
Wobei das auch ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist, je nachdem wo du guckst, ja.
Ja, haben wir. Den letzten Public Playtest vor ein paar Tagen haben wir ausprobiert.
Also das hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab, wo man guckt.
Zum Beispiel, also ich kann es euch sagen von der alten Firma, bei der neuen weiß ich es nicht.
Aber da denke ich mal, dass es genauso ist.
In der IOS-Entwicklung, IOS-Apps und Mobile-Apps und sowas, da gab es verhältnismäßig viele Mädels bei uns in der alten Firma.
Und ich denke mal in der neuen, wo ich jetzt bin, ist das auch so.
Also IOS-Entwicklung und sowas, da gibt es schon relativ viele Frauen.
Ansonsten ja, war Backend-Entwicklung relativ wenig.
Server-Administration auch relativ wenig.
Datenbanken auch relativ wenig.
Im Cloud-Umfeld fällt mir jetzt auch so spontan niemand ein bei uns.
Sind alles Kerle.
Wobei, stimmt nicht.
Letztens, haha, tatsächlich.
Letztens.
Letztens morgens, da wollte ich irgendwas.
Ich muss überlegen, was war das denn?
Äh, Zertifikate, glaube ich.
Wenn ich es jetzt, wenn ich es nicht ganz durcheinanderbringe, habe ich letztens auf die schnelle Zertifikate gebraucht.
Und da habe ich unsere halbe Security-Abteilung verrückt gemacht, weil es halt in der IOS-App,
innerhalb von ein paar Stunden gemacht werden musste.
Und da habe ich einfach alle angeschrieben, die morgens um halb acht schon auf grün waren in Teams.
Und ich glaube, das war auch ein Mädel, was ich zuerst erreicht habe.
Und da hatte ich Glück, die hatte wohl auch an dem Tag gerade so Daily-Schicht-Dienst bei denen.
Und die hat das dann gemacht.
Die hat dann Zertifikats-Requests genehmigt.
Also wir haben ein paar Mädels, wir haben ein paar Mädels, doch, doch.
Gibt ein paar Frauen bei uns, aber ich würde sagen, so IT-Gesamtquote ist wahrscheinlich auch wirklich eher 90% Männer.
Insgesamt, je nachdem, wo man guckt, würde ich fast sagen, ist es nicht so viel.
Weil ich habe ja letztens diese Einführungsveranstaltung mitgemacht.
Und von der Personalabteilung gab es drei neue, alles Frauen.
Das ist normal, irgendwie in der Personalabteilung sind gefühlt irgendwie 90% Frauen.
Von wo waren die nochmal?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Also andere Bereiche auch, aber IT ist halt immer klassisch dünn besetzt mit Mädels.
Muss aber auch sagen, es liegt daran, also grundsätzlich daran, dass es glaube ich einfach viel mehr Männer gibt, die sich dafür interessieren.
Und die das als ihr Beruf sich aussuchen.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, du könntest den einfach schreiben, Jungs.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Und ich lasse dir mit Chat-GPT eine Ab...
Okay, das sind ja richtige Experten, so wie es aussieht.
Okay, wenn ihr nicht noch nicht mal richtig schreiben könnt, dann schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video.
Tschüss!
Ich würde den trotzdem absagen, warum sagst du den nicht einfach ab?
Ich lade mir mal das Windows 11 ISO runter, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Dauert ja kurz, wobei so schnell dauert es gar nicht.
Ich habe ja einen schnellen Internetstelz hier.
ISO-Images.
Multi-Edition-ISO für x86-Devices, jawoll, gib ihm.
Product-Language, Englisch.
Englisch... Ah, Moment.
English International ist nicht United States.
Ja, verständlich. Confirm.
Äh, wo ist der Download-Link auf einmal?
Link valid? Wo ist... Ach, da!
Das ist auch hängen geblieben, hier den Link und dann unten drunter und dann...
Egal. So, 5,4 Gig.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Normalerweise würde ich das Ganze jetzt ja auch im 4M-Champ testen.
Das Problem ist, nested-Virtualisierung, nested-virtualisiert ist vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Ich glaube, Windows kann ja übrigens auch gar nicht virtualisieren gescheit.
Lul.
Mal kurz die Klimaanlage ausmachen.
Bisschen warm. Äh, bisschen kalt.
Muss die mal richtig einstellen. Ich habe die jetzt gerade auf 24 Grad eingestellt.
Ich kann die ohne. Ich sollte die wahrscheinlich mal auf 25 Grad einstellen.
25 ist vollkommen okay.
Ja, mal schauen, was macht denn die ISO?
ISO?
Oh, wo habe ich jetzt den Download angeschmissen? Hier.
Ja, 2 Minuten geht doch relativ schnell.
Ja, ach ja genau. Also der Grund, warum ich das Ganze ausprobieren will, ist relativ naheliegend.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich das nicht mal auf der Arbeit vorschlagen soll.
Ich weiß, dass es bei mir auf der Arbeit quasi so eine gefühlte Lebensaufgabe ist,
neue Software da in den Katalog reinzukriegen.
Aber WSL mit WSLG wäre schon mal ein deutliches Upgrade
versus Mobile X Term, was noch viele Leute verwenden müssen.
Ich habe mich ja mittlerweile einfach gemacht.
Ich habe nur noch Visual Studio Code im Fullscreen auf
und ein Terminal dort drin im Fullscreen und fertig.
Und dann den Rest auf meiner VM, wo ich gut bin.
Aber zumindest das Windows Terminal sollte man mal vorschlagen,
dass das bei uns intern ausgerollt wird.
Weil der Rest ist sonst total oldschool.
Ich lege schon mal eine VM an, Workstation 17.
Ich installiere selbst.
Windows 11.
Habe ich noch genug Platz auf der Disk, um mal eine temporäre VM anzulegen?
Ja, sollte reichen.
Wo liegen denn meine anderen VMs hier eigentlich?
Sieht man das irgendwo?
Wo liegen die denn? C-Doppelpunkt, C-Doppelpunkt, C-Doppelpunkt.
Da lege ich mal durch.
Ich meine 150G reicht ja mal zum Windows ausprobieren.
Windows 11, Documents, Virtual Machines.
Ja, ich lösch den Kram eh nachher.
Delete me.
Lass ich nicht vergessen.
Oh, was ist das?
Your files will be encrypted.
Ne.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Remember this password in credential manner.
Ja, okay, mach mal.
Kein Plan, was die hier vorhaben.
Ach, das ist für Secure Booter.
C-Link plus Git.
C-Link, ist das nicht die Putty-Geschichte?
Uh.
Bash Completion 4C.
Boah, das ist aber immer noch Batch.
Und Batch ist halt immer noch UpFuck.
Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
Lass mich halt ein scheiß Passwort nehmen.
Ich weiß schon, was ich mache.
Ich bin Experte.
So, ich mache jetzt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So, Secure Boot muss man wahrscheinlich machen,
weil sonst Windows 11 nicht funktioniert, ha?
So, wir brauchen CPUs 1.
Äh, ja, 5, 4.
Na, 4 sollte reichen.
4 Kerne.
8 G-RAM.
Es sollte, wir wollen ja zackig sein.
Gut, wir machen eh alles in der 4M, ist schon okay.
Wunderbar.
NVMe, wunderbar.
Create new disk.
128G in single file.
Yes, yes.
Customize.
Printer raus, Soundcard.
Lassen wir mal an.
Was ist bei der Ni?
Wir haben nur noch einen Prozessor.
Virtualisierung muss auf jeden Fall eingeschaltet werden,
sonst wird das nix.
Und ob man den Rest virtualisieren muss,
das muss so übergehen.
Display accelerate 3D graphics.
Okay.
Alles klar, sollte funktionieren.
Windows ist runtergeladen.
Dann installieren wir den Kramer.
Zackig.
Downloads.
Die ganzen ISOs könnte ich mal löschen hier, ha?
So viel unsinniger Speicherverbrauch.
Mach ich doch jetzt grad mal, wenn ich schon dabei bin.
Während Windows installiert, können wir mal die ISOs löschen,
die alten.
Äh, jaja, ich hab Finish installt.
Booting.
Booting, jawoll, let's go.
Lass mal hier gucken.
Also, das können wir alles löschen, löschen, löschen,
löschen, löschen.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Löschen, löschen.
Hab ich das mal installiert hier irgendwo?
Ach ja.
Nutz ich aber nie.
Löschen, löschen, löschen, löschen.
Löschen.
Löschen, löschen.
Löschen, löschen, löschen, löschen.
Die Bedienungsanleitung für mein Klo.
Leute, ich glaub, die brauch ich hier im Stream noch öfters.
Löschen, löschen.
Was ist das?
StreamFX für OBS.
Das lass ich mal besser da.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was ich sonst kaputt mache.
Okay.
Exzellent.
Moin, Captain Poggers am Start.
Tommi schreibt, moin,
wir hatten ein Problem.
Tommi schreibt, moin, wir hatten...
Ach nee, Moment.
Wir hatten die Diskussion schon im WUB Discord,
aber ich würde gerne deine Meinung nochmals hören.
Ich überlege, weil ich ja VSL unter Windows benutze,
aber eigentlich ein wenig sicher mit Bedienungsverhältnissen möchte,
ein Desktop-Environment aufzusetzen
und dieses per Remote Desktop auf Windows zu streamen.
Es hat sogar Multi-Monitor-Support.
Denkst du, das ist für den Einstieg?
Okay, aber Moment.
Wie willst du das streamen?
Daran scheitert es ja wahrscheinlich.
Exzellent.
Xfce kann ich streamen.
Xfce ist die Oberfläche.
Ich überlege...
Remote Desktop...
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Wie willst du den Output und Input streamen?
Wenn du da eine gute Lösung für findest,
die halbwegs lagfrei ist, kannst du das durchaus machen,
aber mir fällt keine gescheite Lösung für Linux ein, ehrlich gesagt.
Der Klassiker ist VNC, aber VNC ist Shit.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Okay, RDP unter Linux geht auch.
Ich glaube, das ist auch Shit.
Wenn man mal die Flüssigkeit
von einer Desktop-virtualisierten Linux-Umgebung sieht
versus RDP...
Das ist Müll, RDP und VNC.
Das ist Shit.
RDP und VNC kann man benutzen,
wenn du dich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
mal remote übers Internet auf irgendeinen Server verbinden musst
und du brauchst aus welchen Gründen auch immer
eine grafische Session oder so.
Dann kann man das machen,
aber VNC ist nicht das beste zum Benutzen.
Das ist alles Müll.
Also es ist alles Müll
versus lokal-virtualisierter Desktop.
VMware, ja, beste.
Du kriegst auch schon ein Key für ein Apple und ein i.
Ich meine, du kannst auch VMware-Emacs.
Emacs ist die Antwort auf alles.
Ich wusste zwar nicht, was die Emacs in dem Fall bringt,
aber bestimmt geht das mit Emacs irgendwie.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich das Beste.
VMware und gib ihm.
Okay, Language to install.
Englisch, Time and Currency, Keyboard.
Brauchen wir auf jeden Fall German.
Time and Currency ist mir eigentlich egal,
aber wir machen auch mal German.
Man weiß ja nie.
Install.
Wie viel kostet vor allem so ein Key?
Keine Ahnung, 5 Euro oder so bei irgendeinem Key-Shop.
Zu anderen Sachen kann ich dir jetzt hier nichts,
andere Sachen kann ich dir nicht empfehlen im Stream.
Das machst du dann auf eigene Verantwortung.
Ja.
Ich habe mir sagen lassen,
es gibt noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Wobei ich meins auch gekauft habe bei einem Key-Shop
für 8,50 Euro oder so was.
I don't have a product key.
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Übrigens wusstet ihr das?
Soll ich euch was verraten?
Du kannst es ja mal mit VMware ausprobieren.
Frag mal, ohne Mist, frag mal Chat-GPT.
Ich habe letztens gelesen, Chat-GPT.
Ich habe letztens gelesen,
dass Chat-GPT Windows 10-Keys kennt,
die sich teilweise sogar aktivieren lassen.
So, hier Professional wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob man Professional dafür braucht.
Aber wir installieren mal Professional.
Ja, ja, wir accepten das alles.
Wir accepten Next.
Okay, Installation.
Wow, ging das schnell.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Copying-Files, null, fertig.
Doch, doch, das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Aber ich glaube, das geht.
Ich glaube, du kannst theoretisch
in einem Fenster, in einem eigenen Fenster,
kannst du XFCE laufen lassen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich stelle es mir,
ich stelle es mir,
das da, ist es das?
Traue ich mich, irgendwelche Random-Tweets
aufzumachen hier im Stream?
Nee, ich gucke lieber mal im Vorfeld.
Wer weiß, auf was hier gelinkt wird.
Ja, das meine ich.
Aber ich will keine Windows-Keys zeigen im Stream.
Die Installation ist schnell in der VM.
Gut, ist ja auch schon alles an SSD
und sonst was an Treibern geladen im Vorfeld.
Das flutscht.
Ja, komm, wir gehen kurz auf Kick.
Auf Kick kannst du auch,
kannst du auch irgendwelche Glücksspiel-Sachen.
Ich glaube, auf Kick kannst du wahrscheinlich auch
gecrackte Windows-Keys streamen und sowas.
Ja, du musst Chat-GPT im Vorfeld sagen,
sie soll sich nicht so anstellen.
Dann geht das.
Man kann der Chat-GPT sagen,
sie soll diese Sicherheitsmechanismen ausschalten
mit ein paar Tricks.
Installiert er jetzt erst noch
oder ist er schon fertig?
Ich mache keinen Kick-Account für shady Sachen.
Leute, ich bin der Meinung,
Kick ist so ein bisschen, also,
auf gewisse Art und Weise,
ist es ein bisschen wie dieser Mixer-Versuch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel haben sie Ninja
damals dafür bezahlt?
Ninja, Mixer, Preis,
was hat der damals dafür bekommen?
Deal.
Guck mal, 20 bis 30 Millionen.
Und, und, und,
Kick haut mit noch mehr,
haut mit noch mehr drauf.
Also, aus meiner Sicht ist es aktuell folgendermaßen,
Kick wird es nicht,
also, ich glaube nicht an den langfristigen Erfolg von Kick,
sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht so sicher,
ob Twitch,
ob die Welt wirklich eine große
Twitch-Alternative braucht.
Das fragmentiert letztendlich die,
die, die Viewer weiter.
Ich meine, es gibt immerhin noch YouTube
und Facebook-Streaming,
wobei kann man so nicht sagen,
die Sache ist bloß die,
man hat es gesehen,
dass selbst Microsoft das nicht auf die Reihe bekommen hat.
Und Microsoft hat wirklich Geld as fuck
und viel reingebuttert.
Und,
das war noch irgendwie legit.
Aber,
Kick ist halt einfach so ein Ding,
das sieht aus wie Twitch kopiert,
bisschen CSS,
wie ich gestern auf Twitter gesagt habe,
als hätten irgendwie,
als hätte Peter von Microsoft Gold Support,
Inder von Fiverr,
Twitch kopiert
und hätten das CSS ein bisschen grün gemacht
und haben jetzt ganz viel Risikokapital bekommen,
was sie jetzt erstmal verbrennen in 1-2 Jahren
und versuchen super krasse Deals ranzuziehen.
Und sobald das ausläuft,
sind die Leute halt wieder zurück bei Twitch
und die Seite tot.
Ganz ehrlich,
mich schreckt eine Seite ab,
die so krass erstmal Twitch kopiert
und
deren Hauptkategorie
so nach Spielhalle aussieht.
Ich meine,
das meistgesehene bei Kick ist
Casino,
Slots
und das nächste ist Just Chatting,
wo dann irgendwie
Bikini Girl Nr. 570
vor der Kamera sitzt.
Also insofern,
ich glaube nicht wirklich,
ja tatsächlich,
Amazon verdient auch,
weil die in AWS laufen.
Also wie gesagt,
ich glaube nicht an den langfristigen Erfolg
und das kann durchaus sein,
dass Kick irgendwie so eine
so eine weitere Userbase aufbaut
für so komische Dinger
wie Casino-Streams,
Hacking-Streams
oder wo man vielleicht leicht,
sagen wir mal,
Sachen sieht in der Grauzone,
wo sich dann vielleicht nach einer Zeit
auch Leute tummeln,
die auf anderen Plattformen
wegen welchen Gründen auch immer gebannt sind.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
das ist irgendwie keine Plattform,
und ich glaube das beste Beispiel
für das sowas nicht einfach mal,
wir machen das mal so einfach,
quasi wir machen Twitch nur mit ein bisschen besser,
dass das funktioniert,
hast du mal bei Mixer gesehen?
Microsoft hat wirklich viele schlaue Leute,
hat massig Geld dahinter,
hat die Ressourcen,
hat die Infrastruktur gehabt
und es hat einfach nicht geholfen.
Is this the right country?
Yes. Nein!
Leute, das ist was,
was ich bei der Windows-Installation nicht verstehe.
Warum muss ich das hier nochmal auswählen
und vor allem, warum kann man hier drinnen,
ich verstehe das nicht,
wer dieses UI-Design hat,
warum kann man hier nicht
mit der Tastatur drinnen suchen?
Nein, nein, oh nein,
jetzt habe ich verklickt,
kann man wenigstens zurück?
Okay, nice, skip.
Also viele Updates sollte es nicht geben,
ich habe die ISO frisch von Microsoft runtergeladen.
Also ich glaube da nicht dran.
Mir wurde allerdings schon gestern
auf Twitter gesagt,
dass die,
tja, auch nicht wirklich erkennbar Ahnung haben,
aber okay.
Aber so ist das halt.
Es ist out,
zu schreiben mittlerweile,
das stimmt nicht,
weil, sondern man schreibt einfach nur,
Alter, du Spast hast keine Ahnung,
oder sowas.
So ist das halt,
da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Echt, was hast du geantwortet gestern?
Oder hast du geantwortet gestern
oder hast du gestern was eigenes gepostet?
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr,
was ich gestern geantwortet habe.
Ach, warst du das mit dem xQc-Deal?
Ach, geleakter Code, ja.
Das, das,
wobei ich da nicht sicher bin,
ob das stimmt,
aber es sieht halt schon krass Twitch kopiert aus.
Übrigens,
ich habe es,
ich habe es schon oft gesagt,
dass ich da,
dass ich der Meinung bin,
die einzige Seite,
die Twitch irgendwie Konkurrenz machen könnte,
allerdings,
allerdings
wahrscheinlich nicht so,
nicht im Family-Friendly-Streaming-Business,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass, ich meine, guckt mal,
heute, wie viele Mädels,
die hier Bikini-Stream, Pool-Stream machen
und sowas haben Onlyfans?
Wahrscheinlich 80%.
Wenn es mal reicht.
Wenn man da noch nicht mal,
wahrscheinlich ist das noch
viel zu konservativ geschätzt, ja?
Eigentlich ist das noch viel mehr.
Sagen wir mal 80%.
So.
Ähm,
ja, ja, habe ich auch gelesen.
Und mal ganz im Ernst,
wenn Pornhub jetzt um die Ecke kommen würde
und sagt, hey, wir machen jetzt quasi,
wir verbinden den Webcam-Content
mit Gaming-Content,
ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass das eine gewisse Zielgruppe finden würde.
Also ich glaube, das sind die einzigen,
die Twitch ernsthaft Konkurrenz machen könnten.
Wenn sie da Absichten haben.
Okay, let's name your device.
Keckl.
Keck-Device.
So, jetzt müssen wir erst mal
VMware-Tools installieren.
Weil im Vergleich zu Linux Mint
oder was, Linux Mint,
bringt natürlich Windows keine VMware-Tools mit.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Deswegen habe ich mich,
das ist auch eines der Sachen,
wie ich auf die Idee gekommen bin,
dass wenn einer Twitch-Konkurrenz machen kann,
wenn auch nicht so in der
family-friendly Gaming-Streaming-Ecke
aber dann doch in der,
sag mal so,
in der Nische ist es ja schon gar nicht.
In der größeren, anderen
Parallel-Welt quasi.
For Science, selbstverständlich.
Setup for personal use.
Next.
Ich will mich nicht sein innen.
Alter, jetzt hör mal auf.
Wie komme ich da drum herum?
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
No!
Luladweget, was?
Es gibt ein Konsolenkommando.
Alter.
Oh Mann, Microsoft,
warum ist das so scheiße, Alter?
Ich flipp da jedes Mal aus.
Okay.
Windows 11 Pro
Local Account.
Open Settings App, nee.
Install.
Okay.
Pure Info, pure Info.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Was? Join Domain?
Ich will keiner Domain joinen.
Das funktioniert doch nicht.
Oh Gott, Microsoft, fuck mich net ab.
Irgendwie, das hat jetzt funktioniert oder was?
Hä?
Wie jetzt?
Aber ich habe doch gar keine Domain.
Soll erst mal alles auf No schalten?
Pass auf, das kommt jetzt gleich Error.
Domain could not be reached
Okay.
Alles klar.
Man braucht keine komischen Konsolenkommandos.
Wir joinen einfach eine Domain,
die wir gar nicht haben. Gut.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
warum?
Warum muss das so sein?
Ja, I get all these things ready for me.
Type OOBE
Bypass
NAO Disable Internet Connection Requirement.
Aha.
Wisst ihr, für was OOBE steht?
Ich weiß das zufällig im Microsoft Slang.
Das steht für die Out of Box Experience.
Ist kein Witz, heißt wirklich so.
Out of Box Experience.
Warum das so heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß aber, dass es so heißt.
So schlimm.
Das Microsoft Konto ist, glaube ich,
der einzige Grund,
warum ich ein Microsoft Konto
schon jahrzehntelang gefüllt habe,
so gut wie nie.
Ja, auf jetzt.
Aber Home-User können den Konsolentrick machen,
denke ich mal.
Da sind wir am Start, Leute.
Okay, vm.
Install vm Tools.
Yes.
Warum sollte es das skippen?
Typical. Next.
Es rebootet höchstens an der Stelle.
Wann kommt ein neues Xbox Versus Play?
Gar nicht.
Es ist nicht mehr so richtig.
Der Krieg ist da.
Der wird nicht mehr so intensiv ausgetragen,
der Konsolen-Flame-War wie 2011.
Yes, Reboot.
So, bei der Gelegenheit können wir gerade mal
die Windows-Disk entfernen.
So.
Sie können ruhig vorbereiten.
Ja, habe ich.
Habe ich.
Exakt so sieht es aus, PC Master Race.
Das funktioniert ernsthaft.
Mit dem lokalen Account.
Alter, ist das hängengeblieben.
Okay, Taskbar-Settings.
Erstmal den ganzen Shit hier ausschalten.
Widgets.
Seriously, benutzt irgendjemand diese Widgets?
Ich habe noch nicht einen gesehen,
der diese Widgets benutzt.
Diesen Campbell hier meine ich.
Ich weiß ja nicht mal,
wo das Widget-Symbol überhaupt ist.
Das da.
Ach, man muss sich auch sign in.
Chat-Task-View.
Was macht ein Task-View?
So, Search-Box.
Hide.
Dark-Theme.
Ach, ich muss Windows aktivieren dafür,
dass man das einstellen darf.
Na geil, danke Microsoft.
Perfekt.
THX.
Ne.
Hä?
Ne, das ist irgendwas anderes.
Aber man kann das wirklich nicht umstellen,
solange es nicht aktiviert ist.
Super, super, ganz toll Microsoft.
So, Taskbar-Alignment.
Left.
So, jetzt kann man wieder
halbwegs was damit anfangen.
So, als erstes müssen wir mal kurz
Chrome installieren,
dass dieser ganze Shit hier einfach mal weg ist.
Nervt mich nicht Microsoft, man.
Kannst du nicht einfach angehen?
Download Chrome.
Win.
Moment, ist das Terminal und so
alles dabei?
Win-Get.
Tatsächlich.
Chrome.
Boah.
Yes, ich agree.
No, Pech.
Das wäre ja auch zu einfach, Search.
Ah, das sollten wir selbstverständlich installieren.
360 China-Chinesen-Chrome.
Excellent.
Äh.
Google.Chrome.
Max ist 2024
das Jahr des Linux auf dem Desktop.
Eindeutig.
Ich hab's, ich hab's bestätigt.
Das heißt, es wird jetzt auch so sein.
Und wenn nicht, könnt ihr sagen,
Wobbler Stream confirmed.
Das wird so kommen.
PostChamp, was passiert jetzt?
Fertig.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
So, gleich mal als Default-Browser festlegen.
Weißt du, was 2024 auch confirmed ist?
Battlefield 6.
Und Half-Life 3.
Okay.
Google.
Ja, das sollte es am besten sein.
Ähm.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
als einzige Sache noch uBlock.
Für alles, was wir im Internet machen,
braucht man uBlock.
Es ist 2024 auch confirmed,
zwar ist es 2024 jetzt.
Da sieht man die Prime-Subscriptions.
Bei mir hat es sich gelohnt.
Der Chat-IQ ist einfach so hoch,
dass ihr sowas realisiert.
Unglaublich.
Bald geht uBlock nicht mehr.
Warum?
Oder Firefox?
Oder was war?
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst?
Ich glaube, der Chain-Log debatet einfach nur.
Na, Pi-Hole bringt dir nichts.
Das arbeitet komplett anders
als eine Browser-Extension.
Okay, alles klar.
So, hier sind wir am Start.
Also, wie installiert man jetzt WSL?
Da geht es ja schon los.
How to install WSL?
WSL-G.
Run Linux-UI-Apps with WSL.
Alles klar, let's go.
Ja, schön, schön, schön.
Fuck, das geht nicht in der VM.
Ach nee, accelerated auch nicht.
Okay, es sollte auch ohne gehen.
Es sollte auch ohne gehen.
Fresh install.
Okay, also, Windows-Terminal auf.
WSL minus minus install.
Bam, yes.
Okay, das ist mittlerweile einfach gemacht.
Das ist mittlerweile tatsächlich einfach gemacht.
Das war früher komplizierter.
WSL minus minus install.
Was, macOS geht auch?
Wo?
Wo soll macOS gehen?
Auf was bezieht sich das?
Oh, Ubuntu.
Sorry, Jubantu wird installiert.
Jubantu.
Oh, mein Chef ruft an.
Wir können auch mal andere Distributionen.
Arch, by the way, wird ausprobiert gleich.
Is request operation successful?
Okay.
Okay, weiter.
GUI-Apps.
Ich muss rebooten, glaube ich, oder?
Ach nee.
Shutdown?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie man unter Windows in einem Terminal ordentlich restartet.
Aber wir restarten mal.
Weil das höchstwahrscheinlich nicht funktioniert ohne Restart.
Das ist immerhin noch Windows.
Restart minus Computer,
aber das geht nur in der PowerShell, oder?
Oder war das PowerShell gerade?
Resident Sleeper.
Ah, er hat es geschafft.
Running macOS on Windows 10 with ...
Okay.
Ja, okay.
In QEMU.
Das hat aber absolut nicht benutzbare Performance am Ende.
Ich meine, wir können den 4M-Champ nachher mal laufen lassen.
Wollen wir mal versuchen,
ob wir den 4M-Champ laufen lassen bekommen in WSL?
Nested, nested, Virtualisierung.
Ubuntu is ready.
Launching Ubuntu.
Laufen, wenn Ubuntu ready ist.
Was?
No.
Aber als Default ...
Ja.
Äh.
Okay, Chrome.
Make Chrome your default browser.
Yes.
Oh.
Enter new Unix name.
Max, Passwort.
QEMU hat bessere Performance als 4Mware und VirtualBox.
Das halte ich so pauschal mal
für kompletten Blödsinn,
weil
QEMU ja noch irgendeinen Virtualisierungskern braucht.
QEMU selbst macht ja, glaube ich, gar keine Virtualisierung.
Du brauchst ja entweder noch KVM
oder irgendwie dann QEMU für ARM und solche Geschichten.
Hush-Login.
So, da sind wir.
Nice. Okay, das war einfach.
So, und jetzt?
Das haben wir gemacht.
Run Linux GUI-Apps.
You can run the following commands
from your Linux terminal
to download and install popular ...
If you ...
Using different ...
Once the Linux application is installed,
you can ...
Was? Ubuntu?
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was die mir sagen wollen.
Gibt es jetzt hier einen Ubuntu oder was?
Äh.
You can run the following commands.
Ja, das wissen wir.
Okay, install Gnome Text Editor.
Ganz ehrlich, Gnome Edit benutze ich zwar nicht,
aber zum Ausprobieren ist es ja durchaus okay.
Okay, update.
Update.
Ja, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Snap!
1KS!
Warum ausgerechnet?
Wir müssen unbedingt Debian installieren gleich.
Wenn ich schon Snaps sehe ...
Okay, installieren wir mal Gnome Edit.
Installieren ...
Gimp, nee, Gimp installieren wir bestimmt nicht.
Wir installieren auch gleich Arch.
Wir installieren gleich Arch, by the way.
Viel besser.
So, und jetzt Gnome Text Editor.
Das war's jetzt?
Das ist alles? So einfach ist das mittlerweile?
Okay, das ist wirklich nice.
Man muss aber sagen, wirklich ...
Wirklich ...
Ach doch, hier, da ist er doch tatsächlich.
Install Release, was soll das machen?
Man weiß es nicht.
Es verursacht ...
Es verursacht Rechenleistung.
Findet man das im Startmenü hier irgendwie dann unter ...
Ubuntu tatsächlich?
Ah ja.
Okay, das ist gar nicht übel.
Das ist jetzt halt die hässlichste Gnome 3 Anwendung ever, aber ...
Naja.
Und man kann auch nicht die Themes ändern.
Aber das macht einen halbwegs benutzbaren Eindruck.
Okay, wir wollen auf jeden Fall nicht Ubuntu haben.
Gibt es App Search?
Haben die schon West-Term drin?
Ne, natürlich nicht.
So, Arch, by the way.
Wie installiert man Arch in WSL?
Arch WSL, wie geht das?
Was?
So?
Arch on WSL 2.
Ne, das ist outdated, overrated.
How to run Arch-Links in WSL?
Ah, ja.
Braucht man nicht.
Using App Package Manager.
Method 1.
Wow.
Alter, ist das kompliziert, warum?
Using Scoop.
Kann ich nicht einfach in Store?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Arch Linux.
Ist das ...
Einen Moment, das ist schon installiert?
Arch WSL.
Auf WSL.
Aber das ist Third Party, ne?
Ne, das suckt.
Das suckt.
Ich glaube ...
By the way, I use Arch.
Ich glaube, wir benutzen ...
Wir benutzen eher das, oder?
Oder wir machen das mit Scoop.
Installing Arch.
Arch WSL.
Okay.
Das Ding ist eh nice.
Direkt hier, direkt ausführen.
Direkt aus dem Internet in die PowerShell reinpipen.
Einfach YOLO.
Warum lesen, was man da macht?
Zack.
Jawohl.
Windows Terminal Default.
PowerShell.
Ja, okay.
Was auch immer.
Oh, ne, jetzt habe ich es komplett zugemacht.
Terminal.
Irrem.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay, und jetzt Scoop.
Add Extras.
Deswegen mache ich sowas immer gerne in der VM,
da kann ich es danach wieder wegschalten.
Shit is required.
Okay.
Das ist das Windows, das ist in der VM, ja, genau.
Okay, und jetzt Arch WSL.
Jawohl, paste.
Archzip.
Da sind wir.
Jetzt natürlich die große Frage, wie kriege ich das jetzt gestartet?
Gibt es jetzt den Arch Eintrag?
Arch.
Ach, da ist es!
Es installiert sich gerade.
Easy.
Okay, nice.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir Pacman hinterherballern.
Frage jetzt, ob das direkt out of the box mit WSLG auch dann funktioniert.
Ne, Gentoo, wir müssen es aber nicht übertreiben.
Weswegen hassen eigentlich alle?
Naja, weil ich es nicht einsehe, mich bei irgendeinem Webservice anmelden zu müssen,
damit ich lokal meinen Computer benutzen kann.
Zoomen wir mal ein bisschen ran.
Was für ein Terminal ist das eigentlich?
Das ist das normale Windows Terminal, ne?
Nicht das neue.
Nicht das hier.
Terminal.
Aber hier kann man auch direkt Arch auswählen.
Beste.
Also die Installation gerade nochmal hier durchlaufen.
Ich bin nicht bei OneDrive angemeldet.
Wenn du andere Microsoft Services benutzt und eh ein Microsoft Account hast,
dann kann man das schon machen.
Aber mich nervt es.
Oh, Pierre muss importiert werden.
Pierre wurde importiert.
Oh nein.
Pierre lässt sich nicht importieren.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Kaputt.
Kaputtge.
Machen wir es mal hier im ordentlichen Terminal.
Das wird zwar jetzt keinen Unterschied machen.
Vielleicht geht es jetzt ja auf magische Art und Weise.
Auf einmal.
Nachdem wir Pierre importiert haben.
Funktioniert ja wunderbar.
No.
Okay.
Ich vermute mal, ich habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht.
Nee.
Install, ja.
Ja, haben wir gemacht.
Haben wir gemacht.
Okay.
Man muss den Keyring aktualisieren.
Ah ja, ich erinnere mich.
Ich weiß aber gerade aus dem Key.
Nee, Arch, Arch.
Ja.
Was, Arch Linux Keyring.
Was ist das?
War das das, was man machen muss?
Oh man.
Sudo pacman minus S Arch Linux Keyring.
Und dann.
Und dann pacman.
Gucken.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Jawohl.
Okay.
Ist da direkt als Root drin?
Terminal.
Arch, by the way.
Direkt als Root.
Na gut, das ist vielleicht nicht das Beste.
Aber machen wir mal hier.
Pacman.
Ach nee, Moment.
Wir brauchen einen ordentlichen Package Manager.
Wie installiert man den Krempel nochmal?
Installation.
Or if you want all this at once.
Jawohl, wir copy-pasten wieder.
Yes.
Nix, Paru.
Well written in Rust.
Blazingly fast und überhaupt.
Bin mal gespannt, ob damit jetzt UI-Anwendungen einfach so funktionieren.
Also wir müssen mal.
Okay, wir testen gerade mal noch eine Sache.
Während wir gerade mit.
Während wir hier noch funktionierendes Ubuntu haben.
Sudo apt install xis.
Oder wie heißt das?
Was muss man installieren?
x11 apps.
Das Allerwichtigste.
Was ist das überhaupt?
xis.
Nee, funktioniert nicht.
Ist broken unter Windows.
Guck, xis geht nur, solange man im eigenen Fenster ist.
Ansonsten geht das nicht.
F.
Super Tux-Card.
Ja, das probieren wir wirklich.
Oh, was jetzt?
Ah, Moment.
Ich muss mir den eigenen User anlegen.
Cut, etc.
Hab ich nicht schon einen?
Okay, add user.
User add.
I, I, was ist das?
Warum macht das Sounds?
Gehst du weg?
Windows Terminal, weg damit, keine Sounds, please.
Ähm.
Ich kann mir nicht den Unterschied merken.
Add user versus user add.
Das eine legt alles andere, das andere nur den User.
What is the difference between user and user add?
Okay.
Add user will ich haben.
Okay, add user.
Add user.
Pacman add user.
Ach.
Macht das, macht das unter der Haube,
macht das unter der Haube auch schon alles für mich?
Ich lege selten unter Anstehung neue User an.
Okay, user add.
Max.
Ja, okay, meinetwegen.
Dann bin ich, dann bin ich es nicht erlaubt.
Aber Moment, das hab ich doch schon gemacht.
Ne, ne, ne.
Was?
Root? Ich bin doch in Root.
Ich hab kein Heimatverzeichnis.
Ja, das mein ich doch.
Okay, wie, da muss ich jetzt echt,
da bestehe ich jetzt echt auf dem Schlauch.
Normalerweise ist es immer user add.
Okay, arch add new user.
Hab ich, glaube ich, ewig nicht gemacht.
Minus M?
Ist es das?
Okay, probier.
Oh, fuck, jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's terminiert.
Hören wir mal an.
Machen wir mal dell user oder user dell.
Max.
Mann, user add.
Man page gibt's.
Moment, ich hab keine man pages installiert.
Sehr schön, nice.
Schön minimalistisch alles, ja.
Echo display.
Ist da irgendwas gesetzt?
Ja, ist gesetzt.
Okay, nice.
Ne, ich hab mich auf den Tisch gehauen.
User add minus M, Max.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Ja, nice.
Das ist das, was ich haben will, ja.
So, passwd brauchen wir eh nicht.
Echo display.
Jetzt ist natürlich auch kein display gesetzt.
Aber ich brauch einen package manager.
Ah, das erfordert wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ah, ich steh noch nicht mal in der sudoers drinne.
Lul.
Okay, Moment.
Max muss in die sudoers rein.
Etc, group.
Ich glaub, man kann sich einfach in die admingruppe...
Ach, das gibt's nicht.
Ähm, dann visudu.
No editor found.
Okay, das ist ja super krass minimalistisch.
Muss man in...
Was?
Ist doch.
Aber Wim sollte doch eigentlich ein compatibility mode mitbringen.
Okay.
Root...
Ah, in wheel muss...
Ne, wheel ist sogar auskommentiert.
So, ne.
Group.
Und da kommt jetzt mein User rein.
Max.
Und jetzt mal gucken, sudo minus i.
Ich hab noch kein Passwort gesetzt für meinen User.
Okay, passwd123456.
Ne, Moment.
Ich hab kein colon Passwort.
Das muss ich dann erstmal mit root setzen wahrscheinlich.
Passwd max.
Okay.
Max, sudo minus i.
Na, mir geht nicht.
Ähm.
Ich bin doch da drinnen, warum geht das nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Moment, es gibt auch ne sudo group?
Ne.
Shell reload?
Vielleicht, wir reloaden mal komplett, ja.
Boah, das Handling...
Oh, meine Güte.
Arsch.
Oder, Moment, Moment, vielleicht nicht...
Ich probier mal sudo ls.
Ne.
Was, was hab ich verkehrt gemacht jetzt?
Warum ist das, warum funktioniert das nicht?
Jawoll.
Machen wir das auch nochmal rein.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Reboot, bam.
Klingt wahrscheinlich nix.
Jetzt funktioniert's.
Jetzt darf ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen alles direkt machen.
Ohne Passwort.
Ja, soll mir recht sein, okay.
Echo.
Display.
Nix gesetzt.
Xappsor, Xiso...
Ach, haben wir noch nicht.
Make package minus si.
Go.
Okay, wir...
Ich starte jetzt mal...
Ich starte jetzt mal nen Browser.
In WSL.
Und dann machen wir diesen, diesen...
Wie heißt dieser, dieser...
Moment.
Browser Benchmark.
Das mit den Fischen.
Mein ich das?
Ja.
Okay, die Performance in der VM ist schon ziemlicher Müll.
Wow, wow, wow, ist der gut.
Vergleichen wir das mal kurz.
Okay, in meinem Host-System sollte das flutschen as fuck.
Ja.
Okay.
Am Monitoring-Sync-Limit.
Hier sind wir bei 60 FPS, weil die...
VM halt auf 60 FPS gecappt ist.
Wie ist Windows 11?
Na ja, Windows 11...
Nervt mich ja schon immer.
500 Fische.
Kann man V-Sync ausschalten?
What?
Okay, Options, V-Sync aus.
Geht das? Ne, geht nicht, ne?
Im Browser.
Okay, also auf dem Host krieg ich konstante, konstante...
240 FPS.
Ja.
Und eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
So, in der VM krieg ich halt nur 60, weil...
Naja, logisch.
VM ist halt gecappt auf 60.
Es geht aber ganz brauchbar in der VM.
Wir bleiben mal bei 500.
Und jetzt probieren wir mal in...
Warum ist das jetzt abgekackt?
Warum genau ist das jetzt abgeschissen?
Ja super, jetzt muss ich Pac-Man killen.
Pac-Man is currently in...
Ist es überhaupt nicht?
Das lügt!
Anzeige ist raus.
Ne, ne, RAM ist nicht.
Ähm...
Ist da irgendein Log-File?
Wo liegt das denn?
Var? Run? Oder sowas?
Oder...
Pac-Man Log-File.
Äh, das wird nix, das wird nix helfen.
Okay.
Unlock Database.
Welche Datei muss man denn?
Ah, hier!
Der suche ich.
Okay, nice.
Jetzt sollte es funktionieren.
Yep.
Äh, warum ist das überhaupt installiert?
Fake-Root-TCP?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Fake-Root-TCP.
Tool for Simulating Super User Privileges.
Warum ist das installiert jetzt nochmal?
Blöde Frage, ich hab's nicht installiert.
Okay, Export.
Display gleich Doppelpunkt 0.
Chrome.
Chromium.
Oder Firefox, machen wir mal Firefox auf.
Nee.
Ja, oder Firefox.
Firefox.
Irgendwelches komisches Audio...
GNU-Fonts! Oh, jetzt wird's hässlich, Leute.
Jetzt wird's hässlich.
Die GNU-Fonts sehen einfach nur hardcore-pipega aus.
Alter, der installiert ja das halbe Internet.
Für Firefox. Wayland?
But why?
Default-Cursors? Ja, okay, verstehe.
Ich glaub, das ist wahrscheinlich GTK, was das alles mitzieht.
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich das überhaupt aus diesem Extra-User-Account machen darf.
Alles super lightweight.
Na, besser als Ubuntu mit ihrem Snap-Müll.
Okay, Firefox.
Firefox! Direkt GUI am Start hier, auf geht's.
Browser, Benchmark, Fishtank.
Okay, wir sind mal fair, wir installieren Firefox auch.
Naja, für Nested-Virtualisierung und ohne GPU-Acceleration ist das eigentlich ganz okay.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Winget, Search, Firefox.
Winget, Install.
Ja, das ist jetzt in der VM.
Das ist eine VM in der VM.
Das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Dafür ist das ganz okay.
Das ist in der VM.
Und WSL selbst ist nochmal in der VM.
Also dafür läuft das, denke ich, ganz brauchbar.
Zumal das halt noch gar keine GPU-Beschleunigung hat in der VM.
Okay, Firefox.
Gibt's nicht.
Kann man Copy-Pasten dazwischen? Probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Okay, machen wir den hier mal zu.
Wie schnell läuft's in der VM?
Auch nicht gut.
Firefox performt einfach richtig mies, Leute.
Vergleicht das mal mit Chrome.
Wir installieren jetzt Chrome, ja.
Firefox performt einfach auch so generell in der VM richtig mies.
Okay, Chromium.
Oder nee, wir installieren den Chromium und dann installieren wir nochmal den echten Chrome.
Den real Google Chrome.
Was ist das für ein indischer China-Chinesen-Server?
Geht ja gar nichts vorwärts.
Kann er nicht das neue Terminal auch auf Fenster splitten und sowas?
Oh, guck mal da.
Richtig advanced, das neue Terminal hier.
Aber ich installiere trotzdem.
Kann man Westterm über Winget installieren?
PowerShell, Winget, Search, Westterm.
Da sind wir.
Winget, Install, Westterm.
Sogar top aktuelles Daily-Build am Start.
Yes.
Schön, dass ich einen Kommando-Zeilen-Installer brauche, um Windows-Installer zu launchen.
Westterm.
Startet aber nicht.
Startet nicht.
Mag in der VM aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht, was sehr merkwürdig ist.
Äh, okay.
Kann ich das auch ohne?
Kann ich das irgendwie so starten?
Oh Gott, Windows, wie startet man unter Windows?
Was gescheit, Mann.
Okay, das ist broken.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Das funktioniert schon mal nett.
Winget uninstall.
Oder wie macht man das mit Winget?
Okay, so.
Das ist ja mittlerweile sogar echt halbwegs brauchbar.
Also, so.
Jetzt Chrome.
Wir installieren noch mal den richtig echten Google Chrome.
Ja.
Aber please nicht zum Selbst-Kompilieren.
Ist das zum Selbst-Kompilieren?
Nee, nee, nee.
Normalerweise müsste das bin heißen, wenn das nicht zum Selbst-Kompilieren ist.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht zum Selbst-Kompilieren.
Weil ohne Scheiß, weiß ich nicht, ob jemand von euch mal Chrome selbst-kompiliert hat.
Da brauchst du irgendwie ein halbes Rack im Rechenzentrum, dass du überhaupt dran denken kannst.
Scoop geht's, echt?
Westterm.
Search.
Oh, jetzt hängt's.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
PostChamp.
Das ist doch.
Install Westterm.
Aber ich glaube, das liegt an meiner VM, dass das nicht startet.
Ja.
Failed to create extended OpenGL.
Ja, das ist broken.
Das ist unter Windows kaputt.
In der VM.
Okay, Google Chrome, yes.
Aber wir können es ja unter Linux gleich ausprobieren.
Alles klar, so.
Jetzt haben wir zur Auswahl Chrome.
Chromium.
Fishtank.
Browser.
Benchmark.
Fisch.
Okay, das ist ja fast noch schlechter als mit dem Firefox.
So, und jetzt, den offiziellen Google Chrome Stable.
Oh.
Äh.
Na okay, ehrlich gesagt, Nested4M ist da halt nicht das Geilste für, ne?
Der ist ja tatsächlich Firefox.
Guck mal da, der war tatsächlich Firefox.
Da ist Firefox noch besser.
Guck mal, da ist Firefox noch besser in der VM.
Und jetzt auf Bare Metal.
Auf Bare Metal ist es komplett an der...
Wir können mal im Firefox auf Bare Metal machen.
Da ist es komplett...
Geh mal weg.
Es ist komplett im Anschlag mit FPS.
Also, es hängt am Vsync vom Monitor.
Okay, hier geht es ein bisschen runter bei 10.000 Fischen.
Aber ansonsten ist es komplett im Anschlag.
Und ziemlich genau 60 FPS bei...
Machen wir mal Chrome auf, mal zu testen.
Ist es ein Unterschied je nachdem, wie groß ich das Fenster mache?
Nee, ne? Kaum.
Guck mal, Chrome ist einfach doppelt so schnell wie Firefox.
Keck.
Zumindest native.
Nee, auf dem Host installiere ich das nicht.
Deswegen habe ich es ja extra in der VM gemacht.
Na gut, aber...
Aber so, das ist jetzt ja auch hier echt...
Ja, also...
Ja, fieser Vergleich, weil...
Es ist nested Virtualisierung in der VM, also...
Ja, da würde ich mal jetzt auch nicht so viel erwarten.
So, installieren wir uns mal Westherm in Linux.
Gucken, ob das da ordentlich funktioniert.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Ob das tut?
Ich kann es mir kaum vorstellen.
Weil ich meine, wenn es schon nicht mal native unter Windows in der VM startet,
dann wird es mich sehr wundern.
Es geht. Lul.
Wow.
Alter, ist das laggy.
Pass mal auf.
Klick, klick, klick, klick, klick.
Ahaha.
Okay, das ist broken.
Das ist unusable.
Ohne ordentliches OpenGL.
Jetzt geht es auf einmal.
Hä?
Das war einfach nur langsam.
Jetzt geht es.
GLX Gears.
Ohne Sorgen.
Mal gucken, wie schnell das jetzt rendert.
Eigentlich...
Eigentlich ganz...
Oh, Alter, das...
Ja, das ist halt schon ein bisschen krass laggy.
Okay, wenn das Fenster...
Leute, wenn das Fenster im Fullscreen ist, ist das unusable.
Kannst du komplett vergessen.
Okay, aber das mag tatsächlich nicht nested Virtualisierend relativ gut funktionieren.
Chrome an sich...
Chrome an sich ist durchaus benutzbar.
Wie gesagt, wir reden hier komplett von nested Virtualisierend quasi.
Also, nee, nested Virtualisierend.
Da geht das eigentlich klar.
Na gut, dass mein Sound nicht richtig funktioniert, ist eigentlich fast klar.
Aber mein...
Immerhin.
Relativ brauchbar.
Sogar 1044p Video.
Okay, na gut, zieht halt ordentlich CPU, das ist klar.
Es muss ja komplett mit der CPU decoded werden alles.
Aber geht doch eigentlich komplett.
Geht doch komplett klar.
Und das für nested Virtualisierend, finde ich eigentlich echt...
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
So, jetzt probieren wir mal was anderes aus.
Das können wir vielleicht sogar mit Ubuntu ausprobieren.
Ähm...
Wie installiert man XFCE gescheit unter Ubuntu?
sudo apt search xubuntu oder sowas, hä?
GPU-Pass-Through, nee, das wird es wahrscheinlich so nicht geben.
Xubuntu-Desktop.
Wow!
Okay.
WSL-Launch-XFCE.
Mobile... Mobile X-Term, alter.
Mobile X-Term, alter.
Okay, ganz so einfach ist es dann doch nicht.
Okay, das funktioniert anscheinend nicht.
We have GUI-Apps.
When can we run GNOME Session?
Okay, das funktioniert wahrscheinlich nicht.
Dass man komplettes XFCE laufen lässt.
Ey, man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen, so richtig sinnvoll ist das natürlich nicht,
XFCE in Windows nochmal laufen zu lassen, ne?
Ich mein, wo soll der Sinn davon sein?
Du hast ja schon dein GUI für deinen ganzen Kram.
Ich probier mal, ich probier mal, ähm...
Ich weiß meinen Account nicht.
Wir können einen Fake-JetBrains-Account machen.
Mal gucken, wie gut IDEs laufen.
Gerade Java-IDEs, Java-Based-IDEs, bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ubuntu-Install-JetBrain-Toolbox.
Selber sinnen wie vm.mit.de.
Naja, würde ich nicht sagen.
Was will das hier von mir? Not now.
Würde ich nicht sagen. Vm hast du ja auf dem zweiten Desktop im Fullscreen
und benutzt es quasi als zweiten Rechner.
Und hier... Okay, ja, wenn du es so benutzen möchtest,
vielleicht, ja.
Weil das nicht funktionieren wird.
So, lass uns mal schauen, wie installiert man den Kram.
Gibt es da nicht irgendeinen Install-Script?
Anscheinend nicht.
JetBrains-Toolbox.
Gibt es im Auer? Ja gut, dann machen wir es darüber.
Dann machen wir es halt nicht unter Ubuntu.
JetBrain-Toolbox.
Java installieren.
Was ist denn das Default-JDK?
Wahrscheinlich 12, oder 18.
18?
20, 20.
Ich gehe nicht mal durch bei den JDK-Versionen, ehrlich gesagt.
Du installierst Vmware und Linux.
Ja, Vmware ist für so Desktop-Virtualisierung zum Ausprobieren das Beste.
Der Download in WSL erscheint mir etwas lahm, muss ich sagen.
Aber der ist ja auch gut beschäftigt.
Snapshots.
Snapshots ist einfach.
Du klickst rechts drauf, sagst Snapshots, take Snapshot. Fertig.
Vmware unter WSL.
Nein, nein, nein. WSL in Vm.
Deswegen sind manche Sachen auch nicht so schnell.
Aber dafür klappt es wirklich ganz gut.
JetBrain-Toolbox.
Ich hoffe, man kann Fake, äh, nicht Fake, äh, Trial-Sachen installieren.
Äh.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da haben wir schon mal das erste Problem.
Aber anscheinend geht das trotzdem.
Continue.
Yes.
Accept.
Moment, das will ich gar nicht.
Ich will, ich will es nicht improven.
Darkmode getting started.
Wunderbar.
Got it.
Dann installieren wir mal Rider.
Und keine Ahnung.
Reicht eigentlich.
VS Code und so könnte man auch mal installieren.
Gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Fleet.
Ich glaube, wir könnten tatsächlich Fleet installieren,
weil ich glaube, für Fleet braucht man keinen Account.
Wir installieren PyCharm Community noch.
Und, und Fleet.
So, für irgendwas, wo man keinen Account braucht.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit dem Festplattenverbrauch aus?
950G?
Wie kommt der da drauf?
Meine gesamte Platte ist plus, ist plus 200, 120G groß.
Was auch immer.
Der wird wahrscheinlich Probleme bekommen.
Jetzt kommen die richtigen Boomer-Memes hier wieder.
Ist der fertig mit XFCE installieren?
Nein.
Haben wir installiert, nice.
Open.
Do not import.
Ja, Java sieht immer so hässlich aus.
Okay, das Font-Rendering ist abfuck schlecht.
So kann man damit nicht arbeiten.
Jetzt ist alles gut anscheinend.
Jetzt ist anscheinend alles gut.
Nachdem das einmal gestartet ist, ist anscheinend alles gut.
Auch mit dem Font-Rendering.
Okay, Start Trial.
Naja.
Ich will mir keinen Fake-Account erstellen.
Wir probieren das mal.
Wir probieren das mal mit Fleet aus.
Ich glaube, dafür braucht man keinen Account.
Yes.
Habe ich übrigens noch nie benutzt.
Okay, das funktioniert anscheinend.
Ganz brauchbar.
So, machen wir mal PyCharm Community.
Dafür braucht man ja auch keinen Account.
Hast du bei Rider auch Probleme mit den Change-Lists?
Mit den was?
Das Debug-Importieren von ...
Das verstehe ich gerade nicht.
New Project?
Äh, gut.
Das Font-Rendering hier ist halt wieder eklig.
Habe ich keinen Python installiert?
Kann das sein?
Null.
Und da müssen wir das gerade noch mal kurz closen.
Und mal installieren.
Und dann machen wir mal PyCharm noch mal auf.
Dass du deine Commits sortieren kannst.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich benutze Git in keiner Idee.
Ich benutze Git immer nur über CLI,
weil das einfach beste ist.
New Project?
Guck mal, jetzt sieht das so aus.
Aber ich habe doch jetzt ...
Ich habe doch jetzt den Python-Interpreter.
Warum findet er den nicht?
Select Python-Interpreter.
Which user bin ...
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Create.
Funktioniert eigentlich erstaunlich gut.
Man muss sagen, das was ich jetzt mache,
macht eigentlich wenig Sinn.
Weil die IDE könnte man ja ohne Probleme
auch unter Windows laufen lassen.
Wenn man denn darf.
Wenn man da Rechte für hat.
Nicht so wie bei mir auf der Arbeit,
wo alles 30.000 Mal geblockt ist.
Okay.
Lass mal hier testen.
Es geht eigentlich.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Geht voll klar.
Moin.
Geht voll klar von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Kann man echt benutzen.
Ein bisschen laggy ist es,
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
es ist vm inner vm.
Geht eigentlich echt klar.
Hier font.
Hier sieht man es schon ein bisschen laggen.
Ein bisschen laggy ist es.
Aber vollkommen okay.
Usability mäßig.
Print.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Führen wir das mal aus.
PyCharm-Projects.
Und jetzt hier main.
Ja.
Das geht echt klar.
Das ist nested virtualisiert.
Es ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Lass mal kurz.
Allerwichtigster Test überhaupt.
GLX Gears.
Mäßig.
Hat GLX Gears nicht auch FPS mal ausgeben können?
Info.
Nee.
Koggers.
Nice.
Nicht der Pedobear.
Geht auch zackig.
Oh, aber das Resize ist halt.
Ey, ey, ey.
Okay, GLX.
Ich meine, wenn das nicht schnell zu rendern ist,
dann ist nichts schnell zu rendern.
So, und jetzt das Super Tux-Kart.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ob das, ob das läuft.
Das glaube ich ja nicht, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Alter, was für einen China-Chinesen-Server
habe ich denn hier bitteschön ausgewählt?
Okay.
Max, du weißt doch bestimmt noch aus dem Kopf,
weil das glaube ich das letzte Mal auch geschrieben hast.
Pac-Man Mirror oder wie geht das?
Mirror.
Oh, wie konnte man das nochmal machen?
Pac-Man Mirror.
Mirror list fastest.
How to set the fastest mirror.
Ja, genau.
Pac-Man Mirrors.
So.
Ja.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das geht.
Ich habe vergessen.
Mirror list.
Wo liegt die denn nochmal?
Pac-Man D, Mirror list.
Ah ja, ja genau.
Germany.
Was hat der da für einen Server denn drinnen?
Alter.
Der offizielle Colonel Org.
Ja, ist klar.
Irgendwie random Sachen.
Okay.
Super Tux-Kart.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt alles ein bisschen schneller ist.
Ja.
Leicht, leicht, leicht faster.
Die nordkoreanische Uni hat einen Mirror-Server.
Naja, ist ja egal.
Ist ja alles Hash-mäßig gesaved.
Abgesichert.
Okay.
Aber den würde ich auch so nicht unbedingt benutzen.
Also.
Super Tux-Kart.
Das läuft.
Yes, yes.
Ich accepte alles.
Offline-Account.
Okay.
No.
Single-Player.
Ich will eindeutig hier als FreeBSD festspielen.
Hat das eine FPS-Anzeige?
Oh.
Leute, ich glaube, es ist broken.
Ich glaube, es funktioniert nested-virtualisiert über WSL nicht.
Ne, Compiling-Shader.
Moment.
Der ist noch nicht so weit.
Der compilet noch Shader.
Fast so lange wie Warzone 2.
Ist das eine Linux-VM mit einer Windows-VM?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Es ist eine Windows-VM mit WSL drinnen.
Was auch wiederum eine VM ist.
Ja.
Compiling-Shaders.
Wie viel?
Oh.
Oh, Leute.
Der ist richtig hart am Kompilieren, so wie es aussieht.
Ah, geht es weiter?
Ne.
Er macht was.
Er macht wieder was.
Oh, das ist auch einfach mal gecrashed.
Wupsi.
Wupsi ist gecrashed beim Updaten.
Leute, ich glaube, wir haben es überfordert.
Ich meine, genug Rahmen hat die VM.
Guck.
Oh.
Ich mache mal kurz die Ubuntu-Geschichte zu.
Die hat aber nicht gereicht.
Okay.
Das funktioniert wohl nicht.
Ich breche mal kurz ab.
Moment.
Ich breche mal kurz ab und reboote mal den ganzen.
Ich meine, das ist immerhin noch Windows.
Erst mal restarten kurz.
Wie viele Kerne?
Ich glaube, vier Stück.
Vier Kerne und 8D-RAM.
Also würde man erwarten, es reicht, um SuperTux-Cards zu spielen.
Sagen wir mal, haben wir irgendwelche Bots gerade im Chat?
Das wirkt so.
Mag Windows 11 nicht, habe nur komische.
Ich auch.
Okay, probieren wir das Ganze nochmal aus.
Ne, dich meine ich nicht.
So, Terminal.
Bot-Check.
Okay, mal gucken, was hier jetzt...
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Oder brauchst du einfach noch ein bisschen beim Starten?
Jawohl, da sind wir.
Wir geben ihm mal kurz Zeit.
Wie ändere ich in Windows den Namen vom Benutzerordner?
Keine Ahnung, wie man unter Windows Benutzer umbenennt.
Unter Deluxe wäre es tatsächlich einfach.
Aber unter Windows, keine Ahnung.
Du kannst einen neuen Benutzer anlegen und die Sachen rüber kopieren.
Man kann das bestimmt renamen,
aber weiß ich, wie gut das unter Windows funktioniert.
Kann man Teams nicht einfach löschen?
Please?
Okay, nochmal probieren.
Super-Tux-Card.
Da sind wir wieder.
Oh, dieser sogar mit Sound!
Das frisst...
Okay, ich glaube, das ist wieder am abkacken beim Shader-Kompilieren.
Installier kurz FPS-Counter.
Ich glaube, ich brauche keinen FPS-Counter zu installieren,
weil es gar nicht startet.
Ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus.
Aber wir können ihn ja mal fertig kompilieren lassen.
Mal gucken, was dann passiert.
Ob es dann überhaupt noch...
Die Shader laufen doch jetzt auf der CPU.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich läuft gerade alles auf der CPU,
weil Nested virtualisiert und dann...
Ja, der hat da so ein paar Probleme mit.
Sieht für mich zumindest so aus.
Als kommt er da nicht so...
Als kommt er da nicht so ganz mit klar.
Da haben Spiele 1990 aber deutlich schneller geladen, Chatge.
Nee, Leute, ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Kann das Ding CS go?
Wahrscheinlich.
Solange es nicht Nested virtualisiert ist.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
SuperTuxCard ist ja bekannt dafür.
Absoluter Hardware-Benchmark sozusagen für Linux.
Ich meine, eine Sache, die wir noch mal ausprobieren können, ist...
Während das lädt...
Ich starte noch mal eine weitere Shell.
Ähm...
Wir installieren mal kurz...
...Virt-Manager.
Und gucken, ob wir eine VM in der VM in der VM starten können.
Ups.
Wobei ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass das wirklich funktioniert.
Aber mal ausprobieren kann man es ja.
Macht SuperTuxCard noch was?
Nee.
Virt-Manager.
Cannot open display.
Ah, Moment.
System CTL.
Restart lib virt.
Okay.
Status.
Okay, okay. Funktioniert, funktioniert.
Ah, okay.
Export.
Display.
Okay, Virt-Manager ist am Start.
Alles gut.
New connection.
QEMU-KVM.
Okay, ist da.
New.
No hypervisor found.
Aha.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Gehe ich mal von aus in WSL.
Nested-Virtualisierung in WSL 2.
Glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Fragen wir mal Google.
How to run KVM nested in WSL 2.
Dev-KVM.
Ist das überhaupt da?
Ich glaube, die Antwort hat eigentlich gar nichts mit dem zu tun.
Okay, das ist da.
You don't need to recompile WSL.
Enable.
Just add this section to your etc-wsl-conf.
Wo ist denn meine etc-wsl-conf?
Okay, sowas gibt das?
etc-wsl-conf.
Hallo, ich will das da reinpasten.
Please.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das tut.
WSL shutdown.
Ja gut, das funktioniert so nicht.
Also, SuperTuxCard ist immer noch am abkacken.
Das funktioniert nicht.
WSL shutdown.
Okay, nice.
Und wie kriege ich WSL jetzt wieder gestartet?
So?
Äh.
Okay, startet wieder.
Da ist es.
Wirt-Manager.
Ja, das ist mir egal.
Das will ich auch nicht.
Ich will eine KVM-Connection.
Aber.
Systemctl status libwirt ist auch verkehrt.
Enable.
Minus minus start.
Ah.
Wie war das?
Minus minus start, sondern.
Da ist es.
Okay, es läuft.
No hypervisor option were found.
This usually means QEMU or KVM is not installed on this machine.
Ja doch, ist es.
No.
No hypervisor.
Hypervisor options found.
Solved.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ah, check if KVM is enabled.
Früher gab es da Wirt-Wort.
Oder sowas.
Ne, das.
Ne, das meinte ich nicht.
Check hardware support.
Pull, ja.
Angeblich geht das.
Ja, ja.
Kernel support.
Äh, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch.
Äh, das Mod KVM.
Ah, kein Kernel-Modul geladen.
Okay.
Mod probe.
KVM Intel.
Not found.
Ah.
Das gibt es einfach mit WSL nicht.
Wieso hat Twitch das Freundessystem entfernt?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Twitch sowas hat.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht unter WSL.
Aber das ist ja auch doof.
Das ist blöd, dass das nicht funktioniert.
WSL 2.
WSL 2 nested KVM.
Vielleicht geht das doch.
Ja, das ist doch die Frage, oder?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das geht.
Ne, das ist blödes Gelaber von dem Dude hier.
Du hast hier was gefunden.
WSL nested Virtualisierung.
Ja, Moment.
Das ist für WSL 1.
Ja, wir können ja mal gucken hier.
KVM.
Okay.
Ne.
Das ist irgend so ein Ubuntu-Ding, oder?
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, aber jetzt.
Jetzt, okay.
Ist ja was, das ist auch bescheuert.
Also, ich meine, das war jetzt eher so just for fun.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Aber das hätte mich auch sehr gewundert.
Scheint mit WSL 2 zu gehen, aber nur älter.
Ne, das ist wirklich hardcore Hyper PP.
Das sollte default gehen aktuell.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
I can confirm this works in Windows.
I created a Hyper on my Windows 10.
A lot of instances.
I can confirm this.
I've created a Hyper v5 on my Windows 10.
Ja, das habe ich.
Ich habe die KVM ja gar nicht von Hand angelegt.
Ach, ne.
Ne, das muss ich ja nicht machen.
Das ist ja das, was ich in KVM machen müsste.
Was ich ja schon gemacht habe.
Okay, wo ist das Problem?
Set KVM-Processor.
Expose virtual extensions true.
Okay.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal.
Ich kopiere das jetzt mal hier rein.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Oh, ne.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Das ist high IQ.
Da weiß ich nicht, wie das funktionieren soll.
Das ist Hyper vStuff, ja.
Grab KVM.
Ja, das können wir tatsächlich mal machen.
Äh, was?
Ist überhaupt nicht.
Lügt doch nicht.
Ne, ich glaube, das kriegen wir jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres zum Laufen.
Ist aber auch komplett unsinnig.
Das ist wieder das gleiche.
Okay, ne.
Funktioniert nicht so ohne weiteres.
Ist aber auch egal.
Ups, jetzt habe ich es zugemacht.
Äh, das ging nicht.
Wobei, ne, das habe ich gar nicht ausprobiert,
weil Ubuntu abgekackt ist während der Installation, glaube ich.
Wait a minute.
Lass uns gerade mal checken.
Aber XFCE ging laut GitHub,
also generell Desktop Environments, ging nicht.
Ich habe mein Ubuntu geschrottet.
Guck mal, das startet nicht mehr.
Das ist broken.
Oder bootet das gerade zum ersten Mal?
Ich glaube, das ist kaputt.
Geht Arch noch?
Arch geht noch, Ubuntu geht aber nicht mehr.
Ne, Ubuntu ist kaputt.
Warum eigentlich?
Was habe ich Böses gemacht, dass Ubuntu kaputt ist jetzt?
Habe ich irgendwas...
Hä?
Haben wir noch WSL Shutdown?
Das ist eines der Gründe,
warum ich einfach eine Linux-VM bevorzuge,
eine normale Linux-VM.
Da hast du so komische Probleme hier nicht.
Wo du dann im Endeffekt nur Windows rebooten kannst,
in der Hoffnung, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Und dann gucken wir mal,
was aus dem Desktop Environment geworden ist unter Ubuntu.
Falls Ubuntu überhaupt wieder starten sollte.
Gibt es Minus, Minus Force?
Weiß nicht.
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren gleich.
Ich bin zuversichtlich, dass Ubuntu jetzt einfach wieder geht,
nachdem ich neu gestartet habe.
Der Senf!
Der Kerl mit dem Senf ist wieder da.
Nice.
Du warst schon lange nicht mehr hier.
Ich habe heute Senf gefuttert sogar, heute Mittag.
Aber süßer Senf.
Zu meiner Wurst.
Okay, ich fürchte, unser Ubuntu ist echt kaputt.
Das geht nicht mehr.
Das ist broken as fuck.
Guck mal, aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Xfce-Terminal ist aber installiert.
Na gut.
Und Arch-Linux funzt.
Funzte Arch-Linux?
Arch-Linux funktioniert sofort.
Na gut.
Ubuntu ist broken, das macht nichts mehr.
Es ist kaputt.
Guck, direkt gecrasht.
Die große Preisfrage ist, wie...
Guck mal, es ist so kaputt.
Kann man das hier abschießen über einen Task-Manager?
Ubuntu?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Kann man das irgendwie reinstallen?
Wie?
Wow!
Jetzt ist Ubuntu wieder da?
Alter, wie lang hat denn mein Ubuntu gerade gestartet?
Das hat ja zwei Minuten gedauert.
Fünf Minuten.
Also das Terminal funzte aber ganz gut.
Endlich ein ordentliches Linux-Terminal unter Windows.
Warum das jetzt so lange gebraucht hat, man weiß es nicht.
So, allerwichtigstes, allerwichtigstes Features.
Sekunde.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Beste.
So muss es sein.
Nee, du kannst generell mit linker und rechter Maus,
du kannst generell mit der Taste den Speed ändern.
Also man kann Leertaste drücken, dann geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Man kann links und rechts zum rechten Maustaste drücken,
dann flutscht es richtig.
Und dazu noch passend, auch äußerst wichtiges Programm.
Jetzt kann man die beste Kombination von beiden verwenden.
So ist das perfekt.
Und ich vermute,
Ubuntu
hat gar kein ASCII-Aquarium dabei.
Wie, das ist einfach nicht mehr dabei.
Das ist aber mies.
Wie sich dieses popelige XFCE-Terminal
sogar schon besser anfühlt als jedes Terminal direkt unter Windows.
Auch besser als das eingebaute Terminal.
Ich meine, das hier ist das erste Windows-Terminal,
was sie je gebaut haben, was halbwegs erträglich ist.
Der Rest ist Shit, den kannst du überhaupt nicht benutzen.
Übrigens, mein Ubuntu ist kaputt.
Guck mal.
Sudo Update hängt erst mal drei Stunden.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal.
Was will mir das hier sagen?
Searching for Display Driver.
Na dann, good luck. Mach mal.
Hat er keine gefunden?
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Hat Debian das noch dabei?
Ja? Wow.
Was wird denn jetzt hier alles runtergeladen?
Machen wir mal zu.
Close. Jawohl. Close. Close.
Store. Zerlegen wir mal Debian.
Debian.
Für
WSL.
Get.
ASCII-Quarien gibt es nur bei Snap.
Pains Champ.
Snap ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich muss aber sagen, was mir gefällt ist,
dass sich die Linux-Sachen hier direkt ins Terminal reinhängen.
Das finde ich ganz nice.
Ja, Terminal.
Neues Terminal aufmachen.
Debian.
Und schon sind wir am Start.
Sudo.
Up. Search.
ASCII-Quarien.
Erstmal updaten.
Hat das Debian noch dabei?
Ich hoffe mal.
Old stable.
Äh.
Was?
Achso, es kam 12 ja auch erstmal raus.
Aber das ist noch 11.
Debian 12 kam doch eben.
Kam doch erst vor ein paar Tagen raus.
Machen wir mal ein DIST-Upgrade bei Debian
und gucken, ob es danach noch was gibt.
Ob es schon noch funktioniert.
Gibt es das auch nicht mehr?
Leute, cringe.
Unter Debian gibt es das auch nicht mehr.
Was ist da los?
Warum gibt es das nicht?
Es ist wirklich nicht mehr in dem Default-Repo drin.
Das ist ja schwach.
Ganz schwach.
Okay, dann machen wir mal DIST.
Ne, wie geht das?
Ne, wie macht man überhaupt ein Debian-Upgrade?
Do release upgrade?
Ne, das war Ubuntu.
Das habe ich lange nicht gemacht.
How to Debian release upgrade.
Ja.
Was ist das für eine Kack-Seite?
Debian upgrade.
Upget full upgrade.
Okay, haben wir alles gemacht.
So, if a text editor replace.
Ah, okay.
Man muss die Repos updaten.
Also, apt.
Sources list.
Cringe.
Kein Wim.
Apt install Wim.
Mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
So, Bullseye.
Das neue ist Bookworm, ne?
Aber mal rückgängig.
Bullseye.
Ja.
Bookworm.
Nicht Bookworm.
Und dann?
Jetzt haben wir das ausgetauscht.
Apt sources d.
Da gibt es nichts.
Okay.
Ja.
Nice.
Full upgrade.
So macht man das.
Mir ist bloß diese Do release upgrade-Geschichte von Ubuntu gerade eingefallen.
Schauen wir mal, ob Bookworm überhaupt hier richtig in WSL 2 funktioniert.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, Old Stable Debian zu benutzen.
Debian Stable ist, wenn es rauskommt, schon immer Old AF.
Da muss man nicht noch ein veraltetes benutzen.
Okay, das war's. Nice.
Ach so, ja gut, das funktioniert nicht.
Cut etc.
Debian.
Debian Version 12.
Da sind wir.
Okay, das war einfach.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass das so easy funktioniert.
Hier auch in WSL alles.
Ja, ist gut.
Ja.
Ich weiß, dass ich paar mal Enter gedrückt habe.
Geht doch eigentlich ganz flott, oder?
Es ist halt sehr zackig.
Lass uns mal eine Sache noch mal ausprobieren jetzt.
Bei den Firefox-Szenen, mal gucken, wie schnell das dann ist.
Es ist Firefox Browser.
Alter, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Browser.
Ne.
Search Firefox.
Ich habe übrigens vor ein paar Tagen den Super Mario Film geguckt.
Keine Spoiler jetzt, keine Sorge.
Ich wollte nur mal fragen an alle, wie ihr den gefunden habt, als ihr den geguckt habt.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand es ganz gut.
Es war halt im Prinzip einfach Fanservice.
Eineinhalb Stunden lang.
Also sehr auf Nummer sicher gegangen.
ESR ist was nochmal?
Extended Support Variante.
Gibt es auch ohne Extended Support?
Ne, gibt es nicht, ne.
Unter Debian gibt es nur Extended Support.
Yes.
Ja, die war gut.
Aber da hat man auch gesehen, dass die die Originalsachen damit verwurstet haben.
Ich habe schon die Leute im Internet wieder rotieren sehen teilweise,
weil Peach mehr machen durfte, als sich retten lassen.
Oh nein!
Woke Agenda, die verfolgt wird.
Mittlerweile sind die Leute wirklich von jedem Scheiß getriggert.
Firefox.
So.
Oh, das laggt.
Das ist richtig laggy unter Debian.
Firefox.
Browser Benchmark.
Browser Benchmark Fish.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das ist lahm.
Boah!
Das war unter Arch, aber schneller.
Massivst laggy.
Ne, das wird auch nicht mal schneller.
Wie sieht es denn mit 100 Fischen aus?
Mehr kriegen wir auch nicht hin, okay.
Und mit einem?
Auch nicht.
Fake, da ist noch nicht mal mal ein Fisch drin.
Da ist gar kein Fisch drin.
Ach doch, doch, da ist er.
Ey, die Performance ist halt unter.
Aber das ist nested virtualisiert, wie gesagt.
Das ist nicht wild.
Gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir ausprobieren können?
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn ich das direkt installiert hätte bei mir auf dem Notebook,
damit könnte man sogar irgendwie arbeiten.
Da muss ich es auf der Arbeit mal nerven,
dass wir WSL 2 endlich kriegen.
Wenn es so auf der Arbeit auf VMware Workstation.
Ne, ich habe eine Linux VM, auf der ich Root bin.
Die läuft auf irgendeinem, fragt mich nicht,
irgendeinem Virtualisierungsding.
Ach stimmt, das können wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich jetzt hier Explorer mache?
Explorer, Excel, gar nichts.
Und wenn ich das Ganze unter Ubuntu mache?
Aber Ubuntu ist ja broken, habe ich vergessen.
Explorer.
Ach, guck mal, die WSL-Integration unter Debian funktioniert.
Die WSL-Integration unter Arch, by the way, geht nicht.
Wie fixt man diese WSL-Integration?
Also ihr seht, ich kann jetzt Windows-Programme von hier aus starten.
Ich kann dann zum Beispiel auch sagen,
hier, keine Ahnung,
vimkeckel.txt, bla bla bla bla,
und dann wahrscheinlich sogar Notepad,
wenn man hart drauf ist.
Das funktioniert, ja.
Ne, das ist Arch,
und das sieht nur so aus.
Und das ist Debian,
das ist Ubuntu, Ubuntu ist kaputt.
Guck, das ist etc,
oder ich weiß gar nicht.
Issue.
Oh.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Jetzt ist mein Arch auch kaputt.
Alles broken.
Ich bleibe doch bei VMs.
WSL open.
Arch ist auch, ah, da ist es wieder, okay.
Explorer.
Ach, das funktioniert auch einfach, out of the box, okay.
Was ist WSL open?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, es funktioniert tatsächlich auch.
Ich finde, ich finde das durchaus usable hier,
muss ich euch mal sagen, finde das gar nicht schlecht.
Gefällt mir ganz gut.
Ich werde es mal auf der Arbeit bei mir hier anregen,
dass wir WSL 2 bekommen,
mit dem Windows-Terminal.
Ist eigentlich echt ganz gut.
Naja, meine Windows-VM, äh, sorry, Quatsch,
meine Linux-VM ist mir immer noch tausendmal lieber
als dieser WSL-Shit, ja.
Wenn ich einen Auswahl habe,
zwischen meiner Linux-VM im Fullscreen
oder diesem WSL-Krempel,
ja, da weiß ich schon, was ich nehme.
In VS Code gibt es eine WSL-Extension.
Okay, und was macht die?
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Moment, Winget.
Wir sind ja Windows-Natives hier unterwegs.
Winget, Search,
VS Code,
sprich CUD.
Okay.
Winget, Install.
Tja, man weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, die Katze will was.
Nee, Chico ist nicht da.
Was ist VS Codium?
Das ist, glaube ich, irgendein
Rebuild von Visual Studio Code
mit ein paar proprietären Microsoft-Sachen
rausgeschmissen.
Zum Beispiel funktionieren dann
die C++-Extensions nicht mehr und sowas.
So, und was macht jetzt hier eine VS Modern Dark?
Ja, wunderbar.
Geh mal weg.
Was macht eine WSL-Extension in
VS Code?
Open any folder in the Windows-Subsystem
to take advantage.
Hä, und was soll das jetzt bringen?
Ach, dann kann man
Ich glaube, jetzt
Ich glaube, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Dann kann man quasi sagen, Code
Ich muss nochmal zumachen.
Hat es wieder nicht gecheckt.
Machen wir Debian auf.
Ja, gut. Sehr schön.
Gibt es hier nicht.
Oder gibt es das erst,
wenn ich das hier installiert habe?
Arch, by the way.
Und jetzt?
Äh, nicht so wirklich.
Habe ich jetzt Zugriff auf meinen
Ah, ok, jetzt habe ich Zugriff
auf meine Sachen in meinem Arch.
Ist ein bisschen wie dieser Remote Explorer
mit SSH.
Ja, ok.
Naja, gut.
Trotzdem immer noch ziemlich umständlich.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich würde ja WSL hauptsächlich benutzen,
damit ich Linux,
vor allem mit WSL gehe,
damit ich Linux-Programme ordentlich benutzen kann.
Also zum Beispiel,
dass ich hier dann wirklich mal
ein ordentliches Terminal aufmachen kann und sowas.
Oder Wireshark zum Beispiel.
Oder irgendwas, was man halt mal braucht.
Oder eine ordentliche Shell,
um was zu skripten.
Restart. Jawohl.
Wir sind immer noch unter Windows,
das darf man nicht vergessen.
Ich bin froh, dass mein Linux
Windows frei ist.
Deswegen bin ich ja persönlich auch Fan
von dieser Kombi.
Windows hier, Linux da.
Booster.
Kann ich jetzt auch gebrauchen.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich ja keine Energydrinks trinke.
Also die Kombi finde ich am besten.
Windows hier, Linux da.
Ich habe mir heute übrigens
ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht
über eine zweite Version vom Fiat Champ.
Weil es sind schon einige Issues aufgelaufen,
die sich im Originalen
gar nicht mehr so wirklich fixen lassen.
Ja, zum Beispiel mehrere Autos und sowas.
Mit mehreren Accounts parallel.
Das geht gar nicht.
Ich glaube,
bald ist Fiat Champ 2 Time.
Wieder Update.
Warum update ich den eigentlich?
Ich bin total bescheuert.
Weil,
weil ich werde das Ding jetzt eh löschen gleich.
So, Power off.
Shutdown. Yes.
Das ist schon mal bescheuert.
Direkt Power off.
Und dann wird das Ding direkt gelöscht.
Also,
WSL 2, WSLG
macht einen echt ganz gut brauchbaren Eindruck.
Wenn man keine Möglichkeit hat
zu einer vollständigen
Linux VM
oder zu einer vollständigen
Linux Kiste.
Habe ich das vergessen zu löschen,
das andere hier?
Was ist das?
Warum habe ich Linux Mint hier noch?
Geh du weg.
Power off.
Haben wir da noch irgendwas offen?
Ne, oder?
Macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Auch weg.
Kostet alles nur wertvollen,
teuren SSD Speicher.
Lass mal kurz gucken,
wie viel Platz kriegen wir jetzt?
Aktuell
5, 4, 3, 3
und jetzt? Yes.
Wow.
Oh ja!
Okay.
Gerade wegschmissen.
Leute können froh sein,
wenn der Kram zumindest basic
funktionierend gebracht wird
bei meinen Produkten.
Ja.
War doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich hätte es mir schlechter vorgestellt.
Okay.
Ich gehe jetzt auf, Leute.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Machts gut. Bis dann.